hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't chat with strangers
now this is a simulator of what happens
when you answer a call we're driving
where we - I didn't know we'd be driving
Oh Mac versus fruits
[Music]
I've been goofed enough of that
buttons single player I guess
technically this is reminiscent of every
video game how many times could you
press this button for a score I don't
know but I could present a lot
apparently 164 Wow not even a
congratulations not even a high score or
nothing okay alright then chat hello hi
boy you there okay I just got in the
game you told me not to chat with
strangers and now I'm dead Oh God okay
so there's multiple endings to the game
I've heard let's try a normal chat then
shall we hi hi cutie
hi cutie hey what's up it's fine it's
fun not your business now your business
get anyway we thinking that's not very
nice and um excuse me pardon more this
isn't real Oh gas leaking
but for your life are you okay how can
you know it girls know things
well guys know things to see I am so
full
samesies hi
I can't move my mouse I gave my mouse
danger oh okay
where you weren't asleep actually I was
[Applause]
um excuse you pardon moi ah the bed
boner
Oh God oh god that's not what I expected
out of the bed boner
it's a weird game there's a weird game
this weird game uh hello yes hello
what's your name I'll be nice this time
are you doing nice to meet you
do I know you oh nice - oh no nice to
meet you oh we met once before oh yeah
back at Craig's place really when did we
meet party yeah a Greg Chad that's his
name I don't know any Chad's uh
everybody knows Chad who are you talking
about why would you lie to me I don't
lie I'd never lie why would I lie I've
never lied to you I don't like liars why
did that let's check out whatever
horrible things I have my own home oh
good okay that's upside down now try
actually having a normal conversation
how about that hi how are you are you
good
great nice to meet you it's meet mr. I'm
very smart
you must be fun at parties sorry I'm
sleepy
[ __ ] so am i I want to play buttons sure
flip buttons I'm good at buttons invite
me all right buttons vs. Lucy let's
button
down you are you ready to lose at a game
of buttons oh you're no good at buttons
Oh loosen up my buttons baby oh yeah you
think you could be be at buttons
I've been button mashing till I was 12
baby oh you ain't never seen buttons
this bharden before
oh god mcpot so but putts are so loose
oh yeah that's a good button it's good
button mashing pretty good pretty good
nice try hard
oh no this button it's so tight oh it's
not loose at all this button is hard
oh that do that was pretty fun yeah was
for me too
we should try it sounds great you want
to loosen up my buttons again
I wonder how does your voice sound Oh
sexy listen to this yeah yeah why not oh
oh yeah hey I'll call you baby my number
is I can't remember this one trying down
the call route again just gonna restart
it
oh no that is Oh everything went better
than expected
all right error log hello nice to meet
you same Oh my number is seven one three
one four three one five six fix got it
[Music]
don't know why they didn't work that
should woo SEP 1 3 1 4 3 1 5 6 that was
it right do you have any I don't like
that smooch ok smoochies playing 50
games like that that's pretty cool good
hobby what's your favorite River raid
you don't like that one is that not your
favorite game good shot ready for that
number baby did you call me not really
not gonna beg you okay oh never mind
[Music]
this is the sound of my voice are you
listening it's real good play many games
I love it love it is great well my thing
love my favorite Mac vs. fruits it's a
good one oh it's pretty difficult have
you ever beaten it no I haven't wouldn't
lie to you can I watch you play anyway
[Music]
okay I'm down start the game you got it
baby started it don't know well I got
level 1 oh yeah
hell yeah wait okay hell yeah I'm gonna
beat it for you how do I get these guys
hey oh god damn it hope I didn't
disappoint the lady damn it ah come on
oh god damn it this death I was just
about to try to click on that thing or
something oh okay so anyway it gets more
frustrating because I know there's
something else deeper in here but it it
takes so many layers to get to that it's
it's just uh it's just a hassle to get
to so if there is another secret deep
down in here I don't know what that is
but you guys can find out for yourself
I'll put a link to the game in the
description below it's interesting it is
interesting I do like it there's
something to that but there's there's
something to this that's really
appealing but just a little bit
I've wish it was a bit more transparent
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought in the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]